sem o valor grande desta grande negócio
acho que essa pergunta na cabeça de
muita gente aqui em inovação hoje na
pauta principal de pequenas e grandes
empresas mas é o que a gente tinha o
valor de fato a gente pega a nossa ideia
é colocar os pés em prática e objetiva
as idéias do papel está pensando em
idéias e dessa vez mais idéias ali só
para sendo criativa de fazer um morador
de fato uma boa coisa que pega as idéias
mas vamos lá né
em 10 moradoras mexer com a sociedade
com as grandes corporações como tudo que
muitas barreiras para isso acontecer
vamos observar as barreiras que a gente
possa hoje na realidade são as pessoas
aquelas pessoas que o banco de dados
ombros como navio chega num posto a um
ponto do mar e ele quer ficar parado e
tem para nós uma loucura
a onda impede a 20 e se movimentar vai
ficar parado em uma posição de ambos na
verdade pagando decisão para daqui só
aquelas pessoas que a ouvir aquelas
idéias ousadas transformadoras que fazem
porque querem que a gente faça as coisas
de forma diferente elas falam porque
elas estão acostumadas a fazer as coisas
que nem mesmo a gente sempre fizeram os
anos eles enxergam como exemplo as
coisas no passado eles acham que o
futuro vai ser igual ao passado para
repetir o que a gente fez que no futuro
a mesma coisa vai acontecer
porém hoje no mundo
como a dor e as coisas mudam muito
rapidamente ea gente pensar que o futuro
vai ser igual ao passado é um erro muito
com ela
o segundo ponto a 11 10
a gente não pode pensar que as boas
idéias aparece uma das primeiras indicar
em minas gerais sempre aparece como um
flash na primeira delas são horríveis é
coisa de jápeto 10 no rio de primeira
vez
o fato é que essa idéia delas mas em
meio estranhos que ela faz o contato
elas evoluam e usam o site de arquivos
vão ficar sem buscar essa ideia é sem
considerar a evolução das idéias
amadurecem rápido
elas crescem também as idf onde do tempo
né você desce que aparece agora mas
agora não fazem muito sentido mas lá na
frente com a vida mudando as coisas
diferentes ao fácil vai reforçar o
sentido sobre a espécie de outro ponto
muito importante que a gente diga monet
suficientemente criativo
existe uma probabilidade bem grande de
uma outra ideia que habitam o contexto
completamente diferente que choque com
nossa idéia dessa fusão de idéias nasce
uma ideia muito maior muito maior do que
as duas outras em 15º
isso é fantástico a gente não pode
descartar o poder das idéias podem ter
mas não só de idéias
a gente vive seja um processo uma forma
fácil de chegar ao processo de inovação
é comparar com o processo de discussões
em função de problemas convencional sem
problema pode ser apresentado para a
gente pode ser um problema que a gente
busca do chefe da sociedade vídeo disse
o executivo que comprova que os
visionários do chiado
coisas que a gente não sabe que tem a
gente tem mas não por seu agente não
sabe como a vida pode ser diferente
isso a gente vê hoje em dia tem muitas
coisas que a gente usa hoje em dia a
gente imaginava que até as vinte anos
atrás
hoje a gente pensa assim nossa como
podia viver daquela forma
porém quando a gente olha para esse
processo de solução de inovação função
dos problemas que a gente olha
principalmente na parte daí encontrar o
problema e de achar uma boa idéia na
verdade a gente total de uma funda do
iceberg
é como olhar para uma árvore e da
atenção para as folhas nessas áreas as
suas atas que tal a gente tentasse olhar
para as raízes da ou seja qual é o
ecossistema criativo que gera inovação é
um sistema bom criativo e inovador
é ela que sabe o que a gente consegue
falar em ser apenas três meninas as
pessoas a tecnologia e quando falo de
pessoas em todo o mundo definido
aquele jegue do livro história aquela
figura descabelada fica horas pancadas e
quatro no laboratório e pesquisando há
nenhum fundamento consciência
intimamente aparece com uma grande idéia
é claro que esses médicos trouxeram
várias coisas que a gente tem hoje
contou com a cirurgia a gente não pode
negar esse direito quando falamos de um
outro tipo de gênero foi um dos talentos
da geração digital só pelas pessoas
talentosas que ora problemas enxerga
oportunidades só que elas que estudam
tecnologia e sabe usar as ferramentas
que tem na mão para criar algo realmente
novo
só exijo que eu tô falando falando só de
pessoas
onde tinha se as pessoas não fazem nada
claro fazendo os gols time só ter
diversificado nessa pessoa que consegue
olhar o problema por diversos ângulos
diferentes
os times formados dessa forma são muito
mais poderosos e muito mais criativo mas
é um ponto importante é que pessoas
inteligentes pessoas criativas relação
difícil entre elas têm uma opinião muito
forte e muito ó pela dificuldade de se
expressar de se relacionar
é por isso que a gente muitas vezes cai
naquela armadilha informativos com
pessoas que só a imagem e semelhança de
quase 1
elas pensam igual fizeram o mesmo curso
era do mesmo lugar que a unidade mais ou
menos da mesma cultura fala a mesma
língua nativa de novo amor e dessa forma
mas é importante ter noção de que o time
formado com pessoas que têm o mesmo
olhar ele acaba tendo um raio de
criatividade e inovação muito mais
voltado à atenção à diversidade de
pensamento fora da caixa que a
dificuldade vai ser muito mais renomados
e de misturar pessoas diferentes e olha
como eu de forma diferente pessoas têm
diferentes experiências de vida
informações aí sim muito mais natural
daquela coalizão de egos e essa colisão
de ideia mas quando fala de tecnologia
hoje a tecnologia avança o ritmo ou
velocidade é exponencial da inteligência
artificial máquina se a prévia e max
compreende os carros autônomos grafia
tem muito mais a internet das coisas
unidades de censor do era um negócio
tudo isso parece uma coisa do futuro mas
não está acontecendo logo agora hoje no
estalar de dedos já ter passado estima
outras coisas vão acontecer não pode
ignorar hoje em dia a velocidade que a
tecnologia avança que nunca vista antes
um exemplo de 50 milhões de pessoas
telefone 85 anos 50 milhões de pessoas
38 anos a tv 13 anos
a internet foi muito rápido em quatro
ciclos mas também lendas espécie de 50
milhões de downloads e só 35 dias muito
rápido
golos é é uma rápida espantar que a
gente não pode ignorar essa velocidade
mais velocidade com que o técnico
tentamos como as coisas
hoje se fala muito em tecnologia
disruptiva né é que muda o negócio a
forma negócio a gente olha os exemplos
de negócios que apareceram e
desapareceram que foram transformados em
um mundo digital ea gente pode pensar
vezes que essa transformação é uma
exclusividade de olho no mundo digital
como está vai transformar em outras
coisas mas não o que transforma é a
ciência tecnologia grandes idéias é um
exemplo de dois séculos atrás
no final do século 19 cidades do mundo
como nova york e cavalos e ficavam nas
ruas
são pessoas que só têm um produto de
cavaco comentando a questão ambiental
pela demanda da cidade e começou a fazer
um programa detalhado preocupando a
sociedade
o esterco seu estilo o que acontece cada
cavalo produzir por dia entre 6 e 15
quilos de esterco
pois bem quando de 894
estima-se que nova york uma população de
100 mil cavalos
esse sendo cavalos depositavam todos os
dias nas ruas de nova york mais de uma
tonelada de esquerda problema que ele
estava enfrentando é a população está
muito preocupado e começou a ter que
começar a ter cinco previsões
catastróficas sobre a cidade com
velocidade onde estava lotando mais
tempo na rua mas doença surgida como
selecionar da yakult 30 e 50 anos
alguns diziam que o estado de espírito
na rua podia chegar ao terceiro andar de
um prédio uma rápida pois de quatro anos
depois em 1998
nova iorque incendiou a primeira
conferência internacional de
planejamento urbano
nessa conferência o acordo principal era
trabalhou o esterco de cavalo usinas no
mundo discutirão vários dias como podia
resolver esse problema vamos chegar a
uma conclusão de uma solução para aquilo
pois bem
todo mundo sabe que nova york não foi
inundada por inteiro né isso não
aconteceu
a questão é que havia uma solução
tecnológica e longo prazo que havia que
estava sendo criado e ninguém percebia
claramente uma década depois em ford
conseguiu um processo de produção de
carros que fazia carros a preços mais
baratos
a escala ea sociedade começou a comprar
carros
aos poucos os cavalos ruído e começou a
ter carro hoje a gente sabe que a grande
cidade que eu tenho hoje em dia é muito
importante ver que a tecnologia
transforma as coisas com a sociedade
muitas vezes um problema que a gente tá
aí a gente tem a gente não tá enxergando
as coisas acontecem debaixo do nosso
nariz da paixão conhecimento
a gente analisa a criatividade das
pessoas pra resolver um problema aí a
gente tem a criatividade de fato as
atividades de são gonçalo de estoque são
atividades que tinham voz de conforto e
faz o espírito criativo mas a gente não
tem apenas dois elementos pessoas e
tecnologia uma organização caótica
pessoas e tem método mas não domina a
tecnologia de alguns produtos enquanto
simples parece que falta alguma coisa
o suficiente as pessoas da mente
criativa e pensar fora da caixa que
pensa forma diferente de fazer apenas
viários bom promover idéias criar um
ambiente com liberdade de expressão e
criativo investir em pessoas com
diversidade pessoas diferentes pensam
diferente que todo faz algo maior
investir em conhecimento de tecnologias
que vão transformar o único claro seu
método de canalizar criatividade
souza em cima de uma estratégia do
objetivo
esses são os alicerces da inovação
obrigado por favor
[Aplausos]